cher père noël
jeanne ashbé pastel cher père noël cette
année je t'écris une lettre je ne veux
pas des tas de gamme x qui font tic tac
tic
tu sais père noël j'ai une autre idée
chaque nuit dans mon lit je me dis que
j'aimerais top secret allez devoir tout
là haut tout là bas je suis petit je te
ferai 0 ennuis tu dirais à 2,3 c'est
parti et vit au dans le ciel sur ton
bonnet père noël un pépin en chemin je
te donne un petit coup de main cris
craquera zoopla en toboggan sur ta barbe
je glisse sur le toit mais pour
descendre dans la cheminée père noël
j'ai une idée je me blottis dans ta
poche ou plutôt non attends je
m'accrochais les moustaches boom
bien sûr je t'aiderai à distribuer les
bonbons et les jouets et si tu t'endors
mais moi je veillerai je ferai un
parfait père noël sitter mais père noël
si tu es trop occupé cette année on peut
le faire une autre fois je prépare des
biscuits du thé et je t'attends car je
sais bien père noël que tu choisiras
pour moi le plus beau de tous les
cadeaux est ici père noël mal-être et
finit très lilly